NARRATOR: Egypt,
Valley of the Queens.
January 26, 1909.
13 years before the discovery
of King Tut's tomb, artist
and playwright
Joseph Lindon Smith
and Egyptologist Arthur
Weigel perform a theater
piece for Howard Carter's team.
The play tells the
story of a curse that
was placed on the
pharaoh Akhenaten
by the priests of Amun,
who he had defied.
According to the
curse, Akhenaten
would not be able to
travel to the other world,
but would be doomed to
walk the earth as a ghost.
Now, some very
interesting circumstances
unfortunately took
place when they
went through with this play.
This storm comes
up out of nowhere,
blinds one of the actresses.
One of the playwriter's
wives is befuddled
with this unknown sickness.
Really raises a lot of questions
as to disperse around Akhenaten
actually being real.
Right in front of me is
the sarcophagus of the king.
Now, there's a lot of debate
about the middle coffin.
It has different facial
features than the rest,
and it also seems like
the cartouche where
the name of the king
would be was replaced
with King Tut's name instead.
Now under further
analysis, they were
able to read the
name on the cartouche
underneath King Tut's name.
And that read Ankhkheprure.
Ankhkheprure was not King Tut.
NARRATOR: Why was a sarcophagus
that was made for Ankhkheprure
used to hold the
mummy of King Tut?
His death at 19 was definitely
a problem for the tomb makers.
It ended up being a rush job.
He got the smallest
tomb in the valley.
NARRATOR: But who
is Ankhkheprure?
Every ruler in ancient Egypt
was given a throne name that was
different from his birth name.
The throne name of
Ankhkheprure is believed
to have belonged to a very
important and mysterious
member of King Tut's family.
Ankhkheprure could have
been the throne name of Prince
Thutmose, who was allegedly
Akhenaten's brother
and was supposed to rule
before or after Akhenaten,
but never got to.
NARRATOR: There are numerous
theories regarding Akhenaten's
mysterious brother, Thutmose.
But the most profound comes
from an unexpected source--
Sigmund Freud.
Who in addition to being the
founder of psychoanalysis,
was also a scholar of
Judaism and ancient Egypt.
Sigmund Freud, the famous
psychoanalyst, in 1939 first
suggested the monotheism
began with Akhenaten.
And he thought that someone
in Akhenaten's court, perhaps
his brother, Thutmose, could in
fact be the historical Moses.
NARRATOR: Could Sigmund Freud's
audacious conclusion be true?
That Akhenaten's biological
brother was, in fact,
the Hebrew leader Moses?
According to Freud,
the events depicted
in the Bible surrounding
Moses' birth, exile,
and most importantly, his
introduction of monotheism
perfectly coincide with the
historical record of Thutmose.
The name Thutmose means
son of the god Thoth.
If you take away the
Tut element in his name,
it simply means son of.
Mose means the son of.
Now the name Moses is
very similar to Mose,
and it just so happens that
the story of Moses in the Bible
is set at exactly the
same time that Thutmose
disappears from history.
And we are told in
the Bible that Moses
grows up as the brother of the
prince apparent to the throne.
In other words, the
historical Thutmose
could be the biblical Moses.